initial projections are for a landslide
election win for Prime Minister Hasina
but more than 40 opposition candidates
say they won't accept the election and
result joining us now our correspondent
nimisha jaiswal she's standing by for us
at the election Media Centre in the
capital Dhaka
nimisha there were fears ahead of time
that this election would not be free and
fair have those fears now become reality
well it really depends on who you ask
the opposition as well as the opposition
leader we just heard are of course
alleging that these elections were not
free and fair we also have heard that
the several candidates who are pulling
out which essentially means rejecting
the results of the election however
right here where the ruling of AMI
League held a press briefing we asked
the camera the Awami League about to
react to these allegations of vote
rigging and the Awami League the ruling
party says that while it's very
convenient to reject a result which is
not good for you and except one which is
good for you that being said the Awami
League has also said the Election
Commission will investigate any such
allegations of malpractice and that they
will look into any any kind of vote
rigging that comes up in front of them
so right now no official comments yet
but as I said depends on who you ask
meanwhile reportedly at least 17 people
have been killed in election violence
many more were injured what's behind all
this unrest
well taka remained largely peaceful
there was a very heavy security
deployment and we also saw a lack of
opposition polling agents all across the
city this could be a reason why there
were no clashes however in other parts
of the country where the opposition made
its presence felt their clashes did
break out this is where the violence
erupted from most of this was attacks
from opposition parties on the ruling
party or at actual ruling party on the
opposition party it is also worth noting
that such violence has marred the entire
campaign trail however again the ruling
party says that this was the most
peaceful election that has happened in
this country so far the opposition of
course has very
three statements briefly if you can a
third consecutive term now for the Prime
Minister what will that mean for
Bangladesh's future well a third
consecutive storm for Sheikh Hasina
which will be historic this would be her
fourth term as Prime Minister another
landmark what it means for Bangladesh is
that it could potentially see a
continuance of this booming economic
growth that it has seen in the last ten
years that has spoken in great favor of
Sheikh Hasina however the criticism of
this government is that there has been a
serious crackdown on press freedom as
well as free speech and also the fact
that if these elections are found to be
marred this will also severely lower the
credibility of this government's of
questions will continue to be raised
about that of course Bangladesh many
young voters in Bangladesh who we spoke
to a third of water of the motors are
first-time voters they say they do not
care about the party that comes to power
they want good education good growth
good employment going forward
okay mr. jaiswal reporting from Dhaka
thank you very much